[Music]
yesterday boris johnson announced that
plan b covered measures that
stay-at-home guidance mask on public
transport and vaccine passports will
remain for another three weeks
in this week's cover piece kate andrew
says the past scheme needs to be stopped
kate joins me now to explain her
argument and to make the case for
vaccine passports kirsty innes director
of digital government unit at the tony
blair institute for global change is
also on the show
so kate you went home uh just after
christmas to see your family in america
but it wasn't without difficulty can you
tell us what happened
so as i was headed to the airport i went
to download my travel pass my vaccine
passport
through a technology that we were
promised would never become a vaccine
passport but that is of course what it
is uh now
and i discovered that my record wasn't
there it said that my code record
couldn't be found i then clicked on my
domestic vaccine passport and i got a
notice saying that i had had a positive
pcr test which was true i was delayed in
going home because i unfortunately like
many many people out there got covered
before christmas and because of that my
app was suspended my vaccine passport
was suspended uh for 10 days from when i
tested positive on the pcr now this was
temporarily very worrying because i
thought my travel plans were busted
again
as it turns out because i'm an american
citizen that's the one country
essentially i could travel to without
evidence of my vaccine status had i been
going anywhere else i probably would
have been grounded but also the
information was very odd to me and
conflicting because
in this country you don't isolate from
when you get a positive pcr test you
isolate from when you first get your
symptoms so it didn't add up with the
rules and whilst once i dug into the
fine print of government guidance it
turns out that this is how the app works
i don't think many people out there know
that at the push of a button or the
registration of a pcr test your vaccine
passport can be suspended and the truth
is this technology is far more powerful
than politicians want to emit and it
turns out quite hard to control i think
so far this experiment of vaccine
passports has highlighted a lot of the
negatives and we've seen very few of the
positive
uh things that the arguments around
vaccine passports say you're going to
get out of the scheme i don't think it's
too late to ditch it and i think at the
end of the month if mps are asked to to
vote again we shouldn't just suspend
domestic vaccine passports we should be
abolishing them for good
now kirsty what kate what happened to
kate seems um like a glitch essentially
because she was on day 12 of her
isolation but the covered pass hadn't
been updated in order to reflect that
and that meant that potentially she
couldn't leave the country
but eve just even so even if it's not
intended to have happened this is the
problem with the vaccine passport isn't
there that it gives a government the
power to limit certain actions and a
government that often is not less than
competent
well
what happened to kate sounds awful and
certainly shouldn't have happened i
think if the government's going to offer
this service they've got to make sure it
works and absolutely the vaccine
passport should be in line with the
current recommendations and guidance so
yeah that's a really bad glitch but i
think the good news is with the digital
passport that would have been relatively
easy to fix and update so that the app
does work in line with whatever the
current restrictions are
probably much easier than
a more uh analog system where you've got
people administering guidelines
themselves and having to update a whole
team of people who are who are doing
this rather than looking at an app
but having said that i think that one
person's bad experience or one
glitch doesn't undermine the value of
the tool as a whole which we have to
look at as part of the whole
society-wide government-wide response to
what is a global health emergency
the question is if we think we need to
take steps to
limit the spread of covered around
society
how are we going to do that in the most
targeted proportional way possible are
we going to have measures that affect
everyone like a blanket lockdown or
blanket ban of some activities or
blanket travel bans as we've seen with
many countries imposing restrictions on
people who can travel based on where
they're coming from or are we going to
use technology to make that as smart as
we can and just restrict it for people
who we know are at an increased risk of
having or transmitting the disease
kate what would you say to that
so to be clear it wasn't a glitch and
this is how the app works and if you dig
into the guidance it decides to suspend
your vaccine passport from after you
test positive
for that pcr um now again i don't think
mps were aware that this is the way the
technology worked when they voted on it
i don't think any of this is democratic
but it isn't a mistake it isn't one
person's bad experience there will be
countless people over christmas and and
since who will have discovered that
actually
because of a technology that's already
gotten out of the hands of the state
their movements are restricted the way
that they can go about living their
lives is
restricted and there's no appeal process
here there's no number you can call it's
just computer says no and all of a
sudden your rights as an individual are
suspended and i think this is the
inevitable outcome of something like a
vaccine passport you know i'm i don't
think governments are generally speaking
competent enough to control such a thing
but even if they were we should all be
very seriously concerned that the
government would have a technology that
could at the click of a button suspend
the way we're going about our lives and
i think that the reason we can have this
debate in the uk and you know a really
honest and good debate about it is that
thankfully compared to a lot of other
countries out there we don't have the
same kind of vaccine hesitancy problem
we have one of the best booster uptakes
in the world so far we have an
incredible vaccine rollout program and
for those who still don't want to get
vaccinated we need better education
programs to explain why we need to do
this but broadly speaking this is a
country that wants to be vaccinated and
and one of the benefits of our
incredible success is that we shouldn't
need this kind of technology
to try to use essentially digital stick
to beat those who aren't compliant into
doing what we want because by the way
that doesn't seem to work in the uk some
countries with relatively low vaccine
uptake have seen that implementing
vaccine passports has led to more people
getting the jab but here in the uk when
scotland brought in vaccine passports
their jab rate was still in line with
england that didn't have it we're not
seeing any of the so-called benefits
that people said we would get out of
vaccine passports we're just seeing the
bureaucracy and frankly we're seeing an
erosion of of the rights and liberties
that that we you know really cannot take
for granted in the uk they're they're so
fundamental and important and i think
this is the time that we need to
re-seize them before this kind of
activity and this kind of technology
becomes normalized
now kesley on vaccine hesitancy
what do you make of that because chris
whittie the chief medical officer is
privately saying that he's worried about
what vaccine passports do to vaccine
hesitancy what do you guys at the tony
blair institute think about that
potential conflict
yeah i think it's something that you
need to pay really close attention to so
health passes have got two ways they
help to reduce covert one is by reducing
transmission because if if you're sure
that everyone in a particular space has
either had their full vaccination or has
a recent negative test then you can
reduce the amount of transmission within
that
venue and the government's leaked
research that it could be by as much as
40 to 45 percent and the second way is
by providing people with a nudge or an
incentive to get their vaccine
and or to have that test
obviously the evidence around how it
impacts people in terms of their
willingness to take the vaccine is
really mixed and it's going to be
different for different populations
there'll be some people for whom they
haven't got around to doing it they
don't see the benefit for them they
don't see the point it just hasn't it
just hasn't you know been part of what
they've been doing
for whom um needing to have a vaccine
passport to go clubbing or to do
something will be enough to say okay
i'll go and get it there'll be some for
whom the reasons for not getting
vaccinated are much more complicated and
much more
sort of deeply felt and to reach those
people you need a much smarter and
broader range of mechanisms nobody's
arguing that you shouldn't be using the
full suite of tools to get to that
population from information campaigns
making it much more easily accessible um
you know sharing the evidence and
helping to reach communities who
understandably have a real trust issue
with government and with with health
health services so it's really
complicated but there are at least two
ways in which health passes can help us
tackle covid and i think that um
you know for that reason we shouldn't be
ignoring them can i just come back on
the point about um competence for
governments i find it really depressing
when people say we shouldn't be using
this or that technical tool because the
government isn't competent to do it the
problem with that is not the technology
it's the government being competent they
must be competent they should be
competent to use these kind of things
and otherwise it's uh it sends a very
sad signal about what services we can
expect from the government and how we
can expect them to look after the
population and provide public services
to us as we go forward and technology
evolves even further
well closely one of the points that kate
makes in her piece is that is this point
about disenfranchisement and maybe
educate you should make this point
because kesley there is talking about
those who mistrust government but i
guess the point is that if you have
acting passports those who mistrust
government are then denied services and
hospitality and access to places
so i think this point about
mistrust and government sorry i'll start
that again um i think this point about
distrust in government is a really
important one um because when we think
about people who don't want to get facts
we often think about and very middle
class people who are you know doing it
for extremely selfish reasons and you
know frankly those people do exist but
the figures that the politicians are
really really loath to talk about uh but
we highlight in the spectator this week
um are the ethnicity gaps in vaccine
take-up and the wealth gap in vaccine
take-up and you know it's something like
11
of the rich haven't had their vaccine
but nearly i think over a quarter of the
poorest in society haven't had their
vaccine and you know there are deep
vetted social reasons for this and i
don't think that the implementation of
vaccine passports again we haven't seen
any evidence in the uk that the
implementation of vaccine passports is
helping those groups often minority
groups often those who are more
vulnerable in society to take up their
jobs we need a much more thoughtful and
a better education campaign around this
i want to pick up on that point about
transmission because i think the omicron
variant has just completely decimated
the argument around transmission in
favor of vaccine passports so with this
new variant the vaccines are still doing
incredible work they're protecting us
against severe illness that is the most
important reason to get your vaccine
it's the best reason to get your vaccine
um the boosters are also working
miracles uh you know the vaccines are
still having great effect but the
omicron variant does seem to quite
successfully uh get around infection uh
vaccines are not as protective as they
once were when it comes to omicron
especially there's a lot of evidence
that astrazeneca for example two gaps of
that which would get you a vaccine
passport is not stopping you from
getting this virus or from transmitting
it it's hopefully stopping you from
going to hospital but this idea that if
you're double jab with astrazeneca and
you're in a vaccine passport venue now
you are somehow less of a risk to others
and omicron has dented that argument
quite a lot um and i just think that the
benefits that we said we were going to
get from vaccine passports have not
appeared in the uk but we see problems
with the technology we see government
that can't control it and
yes i suppose in in your dream world
governments would be always thoughtful
and capable of controlling these things
but history would suggest that they very
very rarely are and i highly doubt that
any government that's going to come
along in the near future is necessarily
going to change that basically don't
rely on that look at the technology and
think you know we're getting a glimpse
into what government could control and
and and how well they could do it and if
you don't like what you're seeing in
that glimpse and i certainly don't then
this is going to be the time to change
it because mps at the end of the month
may well have another opportunity to
vote and and the benefits that we've
gotten from the vaccine should mean that
this real push for vaccine passports to
prove your health status when you want
to go about your business and live your
life can be tossed out the window
because living with covid
has has has meant vaccines it's meant
testing it's meant antivirals but it
really hasn't meant vaccine passports
these have been getting in the way
frankly i think of a broader educational
conversation to have with people about
why they need to take up their vaccines
it's politicizing the vaccines and and
cindy as you started to hint at
even the chief medical officer chris
witte is very concerned behind closed
doors about what this is doing to our
public debate around vaccines they
should always be seen as an attractive
feature because scare tactics very
rarely work and there could be real
implications for if we politicize
vaccines in this way what that means for
future vaccination campaigns especially
the core vaccines that we need to help
protect children um so you know the
evidence so far does not stack up in
favor of vaccine passports we have that
very rare opportunity where something
isn't embedded in society to actually
say no we reject this we've had the
experiment it's failed and we're going
to go in a different more liberal
direction and and thanks to the vaccines
frankly we can do that
well kirsty what do you say to that that
omicron changes the game firstly but
also secondly that there's some people
who just will never get the vaccine they
just simply don't want you but if you
implement some kind of passport system
then that means that they've essentially
become second-class citizens
i wouldn't agree with that at all i mean
omicron does change the game but the
fact that it's more transmissible means
we need to do all the more to reduce
transmission you won't ever get to an
absolute stage where you can guarantee
that everyone in a venue is free of
covert or that you're reducing
transmission to zero but you can reduce
it and that's what you should do um in
terms of the equity point i think the
stats on the
black minority ethnic community and take
up rates are seriously concerning and
that you know the um social uh
demographic take-up rates are a real
worry but the worry is that these people
are vastly increased risk of getting
seriously ill dying going into hospital
or getting long-covered not that they'll
have to take a lateral flow test if they
want to go to a club to me that seems
like a very small part of the problem
indeed
i just wanted to mention something in
kate's piece that i really agreed with
which is it's great that there is a
demographic democratic process in action
here i think
new bits of technology and new tools
like this should always be subject to
trials piloting
broad public consultation i think it's
great that there's a sunset clause and
there is opportunities to have a debate
in parliament about how this is working
but what i don't think is we've had
enough of evidence yet or enough
enough kind of public discussion about
how it's working to be able to make a
really good long-term decision so i
would never suggest sort of abolishing
them or ruling them out forever but i
think it's right that you can bring them
in and out depending on the level of
risk and the level of um
concern about covid currently in the
community so it might be that we're at
the stage with omicron where we think
well this is endemic the damage to
public health is manageable and we're
just going to live with this and so it's
right to phase out um a whole suite of
the measures that we've had in place
masks social distancing um and health
passes it might be that we get a new
variant cropping up at any time as we
could do since um you know we haven't
got covered under control throughout the
world and if that's more transmissible
and or more deadly we might well want to
have a measure that we can put back into
place like a health pass to say well um
we are doing everything we can to
control the spread of this variant
within our community
all right i mean i'm afraid we have to
stop it there but kirsty and kate thank
you so much for joining spectator tv i'm
sure we have lots more to talk about in
future episodes
[Music]
you